the media civil war is now getting
really really interesting as donald
trump appears to have completely turned
on fox news and is now offering to help
cnn
crush fox by becoming conservative which
i know this is crazy
it sort of seems cnn might be doing
under new leadership so let's like back
it up a few steps and then we're going
to go through this first and foremost
there has been a growing
tension i guess we would call it between
mega trump world
and fox news
because there have been little hints
that fox news is interested in making
the jump away from trump now if you
actually sit and watch fox fox and
friends or whatever shows hannity tucker
they're still very generally speaking
deferential to trump but i do agree
that fox news has its finger to the wind
and to some degree they want a plan
in case trump is not the republican
nominee in 2024
fox was not big on trump at the
beginning of the 2016 primary and maybe
they want to keep their options open
that is absolutely true
but trump and other hardcore trumpists
have started to say fox has gone woke
fox has abandoned magga and now you've
got to go to whether it's newsmax or oan
or who the hell knows where if you
really want the trump stuff
so
the other
part of this story is that cnn now under
new leadership
reportedly wants to go more in the
direction of showing both sides or
whatever now sadly cnn seems to be
falling a bit into this kind of
enlightened centrism idea of we must
give both sides on everything well
weather report says it's raining you
look out the window and it is raining
but we need to give the side that says
it's a sunny day that's idiotic and
that's the problem that a lot of this
enlightened centrism leads to but
needless to say trump is now jumping
into the fray he posted on his platform
truth social the other day truth
essential quote wow fox news is really
pushing the democrats and the democrat
agenda
gets worse every single day
so many dems interviewed with only
softball questions then republican
counterparts get creamed
right now karl rove is unwatchable very
negative and on all the time
has a big record of losing not an easy
place to be as a republican especially
with all the pervert purchased
if low-rating cnn ever went conservative
they would be an absolute gold mine
and i
would help them to do so
so
this is
absolutely fascinating
the first interesting element of it is
anything but complete prey at the altar
of trump
deification by fox is considered that
they they've turned on us they've turned
on us which of course is an absurd
standard to stick to if they want to
pretend to be a news organization which
they do want to pretend to do that's on
the one hand on the other hand
i've talked to you guys so much over the
years of how trump doesn't really have
friends trump has people that
he sees as being useful to him
and so he'll be nice to them but as soon
as they're not useful he throws them out
and on the other and so we've said you
can be trump's best friend and the next
day if you say something negative or
even neutral about him you're you know
in a dumpster as far as trump's
concerned look at how quickly the
opposite is true as well
for years and years and years trump has
been deriding cnn as fake news
enemy of the people whatever
and all of a sudden now that it does
sort of seem like cnn might be taking a
sort of a more right-leaning approach
and trump is mad at fox trump is
immediately willing to forgive all of
the anger he's expressed against them
real anger over the last five six seven
years
and help them and by help them i assume
he means appear on the network and
whatever else
it is truly stunning and it should not
surprise us if you've been following
this i think the best possible thing is
a republican civil war
if the media civil war becomes a part of
it i'm all for it as well
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack offering low sugar plant-based keto
friendly bars i love these they are the
perfect snack for anyone trying to eat
better or cutting back on sugar and
carbs without sacrificing taste monk
pack offers granola bars and nut and
seed bars each with only one gram of
sugar or less two to three net carbs and
150 calories or less i'm a big fan of
the macadamia white chocolate nut and
seed bar
great combination of sweet salty chewy
and crunchy and there's under one gram
of sugar they come in other awesome
flavors like sea salt dark chocolate
coconut cocoa chip and caramel sea salt
monk pack is great if you're doing keto
i don't do keto but monk pack is just
great for anyone who wants something
delicious on the go without the sugar
and my audience gets 20 off your first
order at monkpack.com when you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout the link
is down below